[Music]
all right amid the whirlwind of news of
political violence in America Lawson the
coverage was a very disturbing event at
UC Berkeley on Tuesday conservative
youth organization turning-point USA's
UC Berkeley affiliate they had a table
set up in the college's Plaza where
members were recruiting students to join
according to multiple eyewitnesses and
unidentified individual confronted the
Turning Point table before physically
assaulting Hayden Williams the
Leadership Institute field
representative who was helping turning
point the actual punch was caught on
camera but not what led up to it take a
look
UC Berkeley released a statement
addressing the incident saying in part
quote UC Berkeley strongly condemns
violence harassment of any sort for any
reason that sort of behaviors
reprehensible it's intolerable a message
was sent by our police force to the
campus community with a picture of the
suspect and request that anyone with
information about the incident come
forward and report what they know in
support of our Police Department's
ongoing investigation we intend to
identify and bring the perpetrators to
justice a photo of the suspect has been
released as you can see on your screen
as a search for him now is ongoing at
this hour joining us now with reaction
the student at the center of this
controversy Hayden Williams is with us
Fox News contributor campus reform
editor-in-chief our own Lawrence Jones
is here all right let me obviously
there's a lot going on here
is that black I by the way from this
incident yes it is okay
none of us you you're watching what's
happening with Jesse smaller correct yes
a lot of people may doubt your story
what led up to it and is there any
evidence that you have eye witnesses
that will testify that you did nothing
to provoke this absolutely so I'm a
field representative as you said for the
Leadership Institute and it's my job to
help organize and train conservative
activists throughout California and on
Tuesday I was invited to UC Berkeley's
campus to help a conservative group
Turning Point recruit new members and
while I was there some students took
offense to our sign that we had that
said hate crime hoaxes hurt real victims
and this this person who claimed we were
promoting violence on campus and and
proceeded to take his aggression out on
us how many witnesses do you have
because I listen I'm watching
train MMA and that shot was a cheap shot
especially at the end you were when did
you start filming at what point in the
encounter as soon as the gentleman and I
used that term lightly approached our
table and began acting very erratic I
feared for my own safety so I I started
to record at that moment all right now
did you try to diffuse this did you try
and say I'm entitled to my view I guess
one of the posters said this is Magne
country is so I don't know what the
trigger is for liberals and make America
great again walk us through the very
beginning this guy what did he do when
did you start filming and how many
people were there with you that's right
so I had the president of the club with
me there and we were talking to a
potential new member when this happened
and these two people just approached our
table as I said very erratically and
started cussing at us and that's when I
knew that this was probably a
troublesome situation so I pulled out my
phone to start recording and his friend
one of the gentlemen that approached our
table smacks my phone out of my hand and
but there were other people videoing
thankfully right that's right that's
right and picked up a wet one how long
into the confrontation that video begin
that you have seen six seven seconds Wow
Laurence I've known you for a long time
you know about this group really well
yeah yeah I know you've been
investigating this for us and tell us
what you found out so Sean you know we
don't rush to judgment on this program
or on this network we try to get all the
facts we have contacted three three
students that were surrounding this
event they had backed up when Hayden
have to say here we contacted University
the University Police and we've even
asked for if anyone has any other
evidence that could give us a full
picture to give that to this is what we
do but there so what we do whether there
are witnesses from the get-go correct
numerous ones yes we know that we know
there were three witnesses but I think
it's also important to know Sean that
this is not new for UC Berkeley all
right this is this
the school that's been burned down
almost because they don't like the
conservative point of view on the
college campus and so it's not just an
isolated event here the conservative
view is under attack and you have
professors that are on that campus that
don't want the conservative view and
students there so it's something we've
got to take seriously Sean
all right Lawrence thanks for
investigating for those Hayden assuming
right now because we're in this moment
obviously which I see small it that you
have those witnesses that would make you
a victim we that person will be found
and we will get to the truth and we wish
you well and I've had a few black guys
in my day but take care of that and I'm
sorry that happened